(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- They're going nuts for you.
- They're Daddy Gang.
- I was gonna say!
(audience cheers)
Congratulations on all the
success of the podcast.
Did you see that happening?
- You know, I hoped for it.
- Yeah, you dream it.
- When you start something
you're like, I hope.
But also I was at one point,
like, doing it in my parents' basement.
Like you're like, I hope this tracks.
And then the success truly feels,
like still to this day,
I'm like, pinch me.
I'm like, where am I?
I'm on the Kelly Clarkson show,
like, I'm the biggest
fan, just so you know.
- Oh my God, thank you.
- My first ever concert was yours.
- Don't.
- Atlantic City. Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- Are you serious?
- First ever show, my best
friend from childhood, Kristen,
my sister and my mom.
We went to Atlantic City, Breakaway.
- I remember that tour, yeah.
- Oh, I was, oh, I was like thriving.
I think I peaked in that moment.
But yes, I'm a huge fan.
I love you, I love you,
bow down, bow down.
- Oh my god.
- Love you.